they walk the streets and alleyways
armed with a simple message stay inside
it's the principal rule of South
Africa's 21-day lockdown but they have a
problem with the rules in the country's
overcrowded townships where few have the
space to self isolate but the security
services have their orders and some will
do anything to enforce them in
Johannesburg a plainclothes policeman
chases residents with a 6-foot whip in
Cape Town a man is attacked in the
forecourt of his own home while a
soldier in a nearby Township assaults a
resident out on the street the security
services are accused of killing eight
members of the public since the lockdown
began the number of fatalities
comparable with the virus itself these
guys may be outnumbered on the streets
but the lockdown gives them
extraordinary power and that is the
problem because there are soldiers and
police officers who have been misusing
it on the east coast near Durban the
police entered the property of the
embellish and when they were spotted
standing in their garden for money and
belly was tripped then a policeman
approached his wife zonker she says she
was assaulted and stripped of her phone
that's when her husband was beaten with
a whip they say an angle Corrections and
Varmus obstacle nanolab school in jail
and she enjoys sharing eysan among some
the corn in Bombay is at Sentara and
guys go tan jianci chloride mr. embel a
says the police have robbed him of his
dignity and he admits he's
stinky salad or Valentina Cordoba gasps
aha moment o Sebenza
monkey must open on the mother open the
Google for tomorrow is a food a pin down
shia foods were magnets in your village
Kylie police station has the Cabot's and
we after ten twenties the embellish
think the local police are trying to
ignore their complaint of mistreatment
so we took their concerns to the
Independent Police Complaints unit mr.
berry said that he went to the local
police station to file a complaint and
they told him come back at the end of
the lockdown we can't deal with this now
that is just unfortunate what it is it
is not supposed to work like that the
police are not supposed to be saying
this is not a time for you as a person
who has been you know abuse or being
assaulted and to be told that no we
cannot assist you just come back after
the lockdown period no it doesn't work
like that
the laws the law says mr. Cesar but the
lockdowns put everyone in the strain
here the police fire rubber bullets at
nurses protesting to the lack of
transport
it's a forceful response but it will win
them any thanks John sparks Sky News
Johannes